wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you do
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some insight into
how billionaires think to get some
success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one choose service and adventure
with jeff bezos any young person even
before they start their career is to
really think about their choices
because
i find young people and i i when i was
young i had i made this mistake too
you can get
very fixed on your gifts so everybody
has gifts you know you you have gifts
you have things that you didn't get
gifted maybe you're extremely beautiful
maybe you're extremely good at
mathematics maybe you there are a lot of
things that you can be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life it's your choices
that construct your life not your gifts
you can celebrate your gifts be proud of
them be happy of them actually don't be
proud of them
be celebratory of them but you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them you
can only be proud of the things you earn
and so as i got older i started to
realize i wasn't proud of my gifts i was
always good at school school was always
easy for me and i was always proud that
i was a great student i got a's in all
my classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to
use my gifts in certain ways to
challenge myself to
do things that i didn't think i could do
to put myself in uncomfortable
situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose
a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life of service and adventure which one
of those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of lesson
number two work with competitors with
bill gates what about steve jobs in
those days
what was your relationship with him in
the early days and how did it change
well we were both there at the very
beginning
the
apple one was a kick computer that steve
wozniak
designed and he worked with steve and
they came and offered it at various of
these
computer club meetings and we went to
lots of computer club meetings so we
were sort of colleagues and pitching the
gospel of
personal computing we were kind of
competitors
the
the time we worked together most
intensely
was after the ibm pc came out steve had
a group actually a small group at apple
that was doing the macintosh and he came
to us early on
and asked us if we'd commit resources we
actually put more people on the project
than apple did and did uh the early
application software that used that
mouse
graphics interface and so it was a huge
win both for microsoft and for apple
when the macintosh became so successful
lesson number three get out of your
comfort zone with richard branson it
looks like you always go out of your
comfort zone right coming onto an island
that was completely deserted no fresh
water you didn't even have the money to
buy it and now you're sleeping on a tent
on the beach trying to figure out how to
get fresh water here you do that often
you did it with the airline i mean i was
just somebody that experienced the bad
experience of traveling on airlines i
was actually
trying to get to the bvi the british
virgin islands one day from puerto rico
and
the same lovely lady was waiting for me
and i'd been away for three weeks and
american airlines bumped the flight and
uh and so i went to the back of the
airport i hired a plane um
i hired a blackboard
i wrote
virgin airlines
one way 29 to the bvi went around all
the people had been bumped and i filled
my first
plane and and that got me thinking you
know that airlines do bump people they
don't care about you or me particularly
in the air and so we
um so i then rang up boeing and said you
have any secondhand seven four seven
okay i mean it was literally that you
just sat in the airport and said i'm
starting airline right now because i'm
frustrated exactly and i think most most
of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration i think you know if you're
if you're
frustrated about something um the best
way of sorting it out is get out and do
it and you've got yourself a business
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four value people
with oprah winfrey you find that behind
the facade of all of your opinions and
your beliefs that at the heart of us we
all
want the same thing i want the same
thing that you want and i know that
whether you are republican or democrat
or libertarian or whatever you call
yourself that underneath every body is
this desire and need to be valued and to
know that what you say what you think
what you want to do in the world your
fullest expression of yourself that that
thing matters lesson number five have
fun with elon musk you celebrated your
30th birthday with a masked ball in
venice
for your 40th birthday i was told you
had a fight with a samurai uh sword
fighter what is your plan for your 15th
birthday next year
um
well so my my 40th birthday was the was
in venice uh it was it was technically a
post-apocalyptic masked wall
uh
after the apocalypse how much clothing
did you really have
you know i said
[Laughter]
it's gonna be a little ragged a little
burnt you know
um
so um
no plans for the 50th
yeah
the half century party
i have to think of something
um
usually go with some kind of
crazy theme
the the
the party where i ended up uh
wrestling with the world champion
tumeric light which by the way also
caused me to burst a disc in my neck
so
you're five minutes of glory for five
years of pain
um
that really hurt
um
so that party was um
victorian japanese steampunk so that was
cool
i
have to think of something for the half
century party you have a little time to
think being on earth for a half century
that's like hey i'm still alive wow cool
lesson number six learn the money game
with grant cardone i worked at
mcdonald's i got fired i worked at a
furniture store i got fired i worked in
a car dealership i was fired six times
from the same guy i just quit leaving
and i've been fired so many times i
finally figured out how to get fired and
keep my job i mean really
so talent uh i'm i'm a sales guy because
not because i wanted to that was not
something i wanted to do
uh my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died tell those
boys to learn how to sell he knew he was
going to die and he's like tell those
boys to learn how to sell and they can
go anywhere
uh i i didn't know that my mom didn't
tell me that until i was like uh 25 26
years old
and i had to take a sales job
she she wanted me to be a more of a
professional
uh so i went and got an accounting
degree got out of college there was 25
unemployment i didn't know it
i i you know i i didn't know anything
about sales i didn't i didn't go to
college to become a salesman
but it was the only job i could get when
i was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling toyotas
i didn't even know what a toyota was
this is this is years ago toyota wasn't
even
uh a thing yet
and um
so i took this job that i did i thought
it was just gonna be a temporary job i
said okay i'm gonna do this for
until i can get a real job
and that ended up becoming my career i
actually hated sales
because all the jobs i had outside of
mcdonald's were
part-time sales jobs i sold clothes
you know i remember selling clothes i'd
sell i'd sell an outfit i'd make six
bucks on it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
i had and i was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things i was doing at the time
and um
i i leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it i was just shooting
some material today for cardone
university we we have probably without
me
over
um
over promoting my own product we we
probably have the most
viewed
sales training system in the world today
and i'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer
this came out of a job i didn't want and
didn't like
but when i leaned into it and said hey i
need to commit to this thing because i'm
just gonna i have to learn how to do
this
i have to learn how to bring revenue in
and whether i liked it or not i need to
learn i need to learn the money game the
money game starts with
in accounting and it might have been the
thing i learned in accounting as i sit
here and tell you the story because in
accounting the top
i remember studying financial statements
and accounting classes uh it was a
counting um the principles of accounting
i thought i was gonna learn how to make
money
that's not what they're teaching there
but i remember there was on a page
in the accounting book the blue
accounting book that i
tested and hated there was a page about
an income statement and then they would
compare income statements to these
companies well the top thing of every
page was income revenue or gross sales
and later looking back didn't know it
then but looking back later i'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top of the income statement
yeah that's when every income statement
everywhere in the world it doesn't
matter whether you're in china or
chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing gross sales
revenue revenue by department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much uh revenue is coming through a
country that is what determines whether
or not a household a department or a
company is viable
and i have been fighting
the top three lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once i leaned
into it boom i started making money man
it was it was literally that simple i'm
going to learn how to bring revenue into
my household
i was 25 years old had no money lived in
a lived in an apartment my rent was 275
a month i was late on it four times a
year
every three months i was late because
i'd go up and down
and when i leaned into it i was saying
hey i made an extra thousand dollars uh
when i was 25 years old i'm like wow
that was the most important money i've
ever made in my whole life because it
gave me an idea that i could control my
income and lesson number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is understand scaling with mark cuban
there's a shark cam tank company from
last season called mush
right
cool stuff it's like this um
oatmeal that they package it's
fresh dried oatmeal that they packaged
with a little spoon and you it has to be
refrigerated but you just grab it and go
and
the the response was great from the show
and now like i just saw their numbers
they went from 50 000 in sales to 100
000 to 125 000 in three straight months
it's not scale but they're growing right
and they're all of a sudden like okay we
got to go raise money and we got to do
yada yada right
scale
is hard not just because of the economic
cost but also because of the people cost
and the mind share cost it's hard when
you're dealing with a major company and
in particular if you're dealing with a
big company like a walmart or costco or
whatever
because you only get one shot of those
guys and so like i told mush with whole
foods
they're interested i'm like you're not
ready
you're not ready you have got to
you got to crawl before you ball you
know and
it
and and and so
i told him it's going to be painful not
to go after that big customer
but
think about what happens if you go after
it and
a it's going to take capital you don't
have and you're going to borrow it or b
it doesn't work out and they return it
all then all of a sudden you're out of
business and so
you're right
that you need capital to scale but you
also need the confidence that you can
scale and that you can keep your
customers happy and so
i always tell people get to the point
where
you have you
you've taken care of the customers that
you can take care of once you can
demonstrate that then you can get smart
money and you're talking from a position
of power and then you can go to the
walmarts of the world the costco's and
you may not even have to raise money
they may even provide po
leverage or po support or connect you
with a bank that does and so
i guess i guess what i'm saying is
don't get too far ahead of yourself
because sometimes sales can be a lot
more expensive than you think they are
and you've got to be careful i've seen
several my shark tank companies try to
get too big too fast and it almost put
them out of business
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the good deed of the
day this is something new i believe that
you're able to serve and it feels so
good to do something nice for somebody
else so good deed of the day put down in
the comments one thing that you need
help with that you're working on you'd
love some support or guidance on and
then two
go comment on somebody else's comment
and give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well or maybe i'll just blank out the
word doubt
um
so uh no i mean i treat totally frank i
doubted us too so i i thought we you
know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who
who doubted us i was like well i think
you're probably right you know um i mean
there were times uh
that i was told like
uh because i was taking the money i
learned from from paypal and enrolling
into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but um
and and and
almost both companies went bankrupt
frankly 2008 was a tough year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon 1.
um and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people tell me this joke like how do you
make a small fortune in the rocket
industry you start with a large one is
the punchline
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
so um anyway um and it was it almost
came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch and then uh and that wasn't even
enough to save the company we also then
had to win the nasa cargo resupply
contract um so that that came a little
after you know a little bit later or
towards the end of 2008
those are the two key things that that
saved spacex otherwise we would have we
would have you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those those doubters were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately uh
vader smiled upon us and brought us to
this day what are your core values
personally and professionally
uh core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you that's the basis for most
religions but they get sometimes carried
away in rights and rituals but that's
the core value do unto others as you'd
have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success unshared is definitely
failure in other words when you make it
it's not really just about yourself
making it hey if you make it you know
you made it but along the way one of the
great lessons to learn
is it's not all about you
it's about your ability to be of service
to this planet while you're here and by
saying me me me me look what i did this
is me hey here's my building my name's
on it you know i did this you didn't by
doing something like that it kind of
takes away from how genuine you are and
because people don't like to just listen
to people talk about themselves how
great they are they want to know
incorporate it to make them successful
also or do something a little different
and i think that's very very important
there are lots of times especially in
the early days that were that were very
very difficult
i think i think the most difficult thing
experience i had was in 1990 when oracle
had its
had its only lost quarter in history and
we've been in business for 20 years of
this 20 years we lost money one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almo we doubled our sales
virtually every year for for ten years
nine nine out of ten years ten out of
eleven years it was really quite an
amazing run we're the fastest growing
company in history still we're still are
the fastest growing company in history
over a long period of time
and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we would reach
a billion dollars in revenue and we were
having serious management problems all
over the place and
the people who were running the company
the billion dollar company were the same
people that run the company when we were
a 50 million dollar company 120th the
size
and i hadn't
had an incredible sense of loyalty to
those people who had worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful
realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that
people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those aren't the same skills
they're just different not one is better
or worse just entirely different skill
set in running a 50 million dollar
company than a billion dollar company
and
uh
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means i had to ask people who i'd
worked with for a decade to leave i had
to fire people
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business asking that you
know
a bunch of people to
leave oracle
i had no choice
i never even asked them to leave oracle
or everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh
thousands of people worked at oracle uh
they deserved the best leadership we
could find uh
and
my primary my primary responsibility was
to the company and
all of the staff
you know all of our shareholders and all
of our customers
and uh
therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go the hardest thing for
me early on was you know because i i
just started off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right
i thought i was going to be an engineer
when i graduated
and
you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on on everything from
architecture to product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off and
i think it's really
easy when you start
building something to um
to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so you know
most of my mistakes early on in building
the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
episode where
we're like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
um yahoo tried to buy us and
so they offered a ton of money
and
a lot of the people who who i'd hired at
the point they were kind of experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they they joined and then you know
within you know a year or a few months
like the the company had the opportunity
to exit for this large amount of money
and
you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for
and
in the absence of
that that context then of course it was
a rational thing for people to think
that this was like a good outcome for us
coding
foreign
what i want to talk to you about today
is a note which i call daily
so if you create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily
and then write the word do
colon and then go down a few lines and
write the word don't
go on
the one thing i would ask you to do
walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note
check it throughout the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so what you put in
each one of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts
is to notice something that you never
want to do it again you never want to do
again and you just add that to it
very very simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back
to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes
show people my fears
because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three
drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
this goes with one of my don't which is
don't drink hard liquor or beer on
weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups
throughout the day i just have to do
them every day
six sets of 30 second planks
run for three miles
meditate on this list
stand up straight
which whenever i say i always see
posture moving in the
audience say hello to everyone i just
bought a heavy bag so i'm training with
a heavy bag so i want to spend 10
minutes with a heavy bag every day
i want to do a video journal every
single day and i want to get seven hours
of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of them
but my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them
don't eat sugar
i'm on the paleo diet so don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the weekdays
um so this list well it sounds very very
simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check throughout the
day and i check right before i go to bed
and i make sure that i check everything
off
and go through it i've given it to our
companies
i've given it to a number of students
that i've talked to as we've gone to
schools and recruiting and people have
come back to me and said that this is
something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something easy to remember
one of the most fundamental things about
it that i've learned that i've taken
away from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
everything else that's going on all the
other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so this do and
don't list for people and individuals in
the company has translated to a do and
don't list for our company
for square we have a do and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no to for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast to continue to innovate and to
really push the boundaries and continue
and question and and reset everything
that we think about the organization
i've always believed that a strong
mission statement's really important and
i have to say we've never succeeded at
it it's like this odd thing you know
we've had them every year for 15 years
and they're constantly different and now
we're also cynical we're like come on
we're trying to make people happy i mean
that's the fundamental thing is in
consumer service you know we're trying
to be better and
us in disney and mission aren't that
different there's a bunch of different
tactics at it um but we're an emotional
product we cater to the things that are
important but not necessary
and i love that part about it because
like when you're selling milk or
penicillin you're selling something
somebody needs
and we get to sell something you want
okay that you choose to do because it's
really cool human you know to uh be
entertained and connect to people over
entertainment and so we celebrate that a
lot and we want to change the industry
but in terms of
like a mission statement like so many
companies have you know facebook talks
about a more connected and open world um
and then you see that phrase again and
again and again and it's a powerful
mantra we don't have an equivalent and i
think we probably would have been
stronger if we do
in the early days um
it was uh to connect people with movies
they'll love
and it's okay but it's kind of like the
long kind of awkward phrase connect
people with movies that love and you
know it's just not punchy and
um and then so like we used it we had
t-shirts you know
and then it didn't really motivate
anyone didn't really stick um but we
knew we were trying to make people happy
with dvds and then eventually it was
streaming and original content i got
an awful lot of good advice from my dad
and and he didn't he didn't lay it on me
i mean he just
you know you you picked it up from him
but there was never any of this you know
do this do that uh type of thing at all
but but
i think he really taught me that it's
more important uh
in terms of what's on your inner score
card than your outer score card i mean
some people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what what
the world's going to think of this or
that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're gonna you're gonna
have a pretty happy life and i think the
people that strive too much for the
outer scorecard uh sometimes find that
it's a little hollow when they get all
through when you try a business and you
start you might have hiccups here and
there but it does not mean that that
business is not going to work there must
be challenges in fact what i keep saying
that life without challenges is very
very boring so if you have challenges
you just have to know how to work out or
how to work around these challenges and
you will be successful once you are
consistent
what business does it like is for you to
try something and then once you have one
or two problems now you want to change
and move into another business that
doesn't work in business at all
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things are nice i like
them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning
sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore
bought every book of the color purple i
took the books to the office and i said
to everybody y'all got to read this book
oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's going to do a movie
about the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits at the
last credit there's something called
best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as
divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found
sophia so i get a call
for movement cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song
would you be interested to come and
audition and i say i have not been
praying for moon song
[Applause]
no
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition you know movie
people they make everything all secret
steven spielberg didn't want anybody
know he was doing color purple so on the
outside of the script it says moon song
but i know all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
[Music]
prayer works
[Applause]
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real
actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track at
the fat farm
it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord i'll come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not gonna be able to see the
other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple just
can't ever see it the rest of my life i
won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until
i could reach the point where not only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
[Music]
[Applause]
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender all
i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i surrender
all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power that was greater than i could
ever know the instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria screaming aufry
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
[Applause]
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired it's really important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to give the what's
in it for them very concisely and very
quickly so with with differentiating
yourself i'll use an example i always
say you've got to differentiate you've
got to tell the person or the world why
you're unique and why you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have and then you need to let
them know why that matters to them
so
i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say and then you
know how our underground options they're
not that great you have regular
underwear that leaves a panty line that
you can see or these very thick heavy
duty girdles that are too thick under
your beautiful clothes or your nice
slacks and leave lines on your legs
okay then i've just given them the
options that are dysfunctional and then
i tell them well i've just invented this
product and look what it does it meets
in the middle of the options that are
out there and here's why it's going to
be important to you here's why it's
going to matter you're going to be able
to wear white you're going to be able to
wear cream you're finally going to be
able to wear all the fabrics in your
closet that you don't wear anymore and
you're gonna you're gonna look amazing
you're gonna have no lines so then i
would give the what's in it for them but
that's just a quick example and i would
always i like to start with the problem
that i'm solving have them just sort of
invest in it with you
and then um why the other options aren't
so great people need to know from you
you're the only one that can do it why
you're their best choice well in my 20s
and 30s
i was fanatical about software
you know i didn't believe in
vacations uh didn't believe in weekends
uh
you know i was focused on software
day and night you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left
and i knew every line of code
and it you know i enjoyed being a
fanatic
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft doing great software and you
know learning from our mistakes and
hiring the best
the best people success is the contact
sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the barber same thing for
the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested do you
think i'm only going to have one car
accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees god gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business you want to have impact uh
usually delegation's important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh
and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're gonna
ship code that i didn't edit uh and that
was hard for me uh but you know i kind
of got over that then i still said okay
i'm going to interview everyone and i'm
going to at least look at samples of
their code well that got us up to about
40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write
because everybody was so impressed
and i thought well i need to keep enough
collect enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out a
uh how to control what promises i made
to people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay we're gonna
hire programmers that you've never met
and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't gonna work uh you know
so uh then i said okay then i would you
know know all the managers of the people
and so over time
uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling
monotonically uh
according to me
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide what scale of organization they
want to work in eventually you know my
role was very much as a leader and a
reviewer of managers but the top people
and i hired some super experienced
people
uh
i would make sure they were pursuing a
common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of uh
you know my
value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office
type thing or to go global
and not use agents to have microsoft be
present all over the world
and
so yeah picking what you're good at and
how you find the other people uh to fill
in those things that's super important
and most founders don't aren't able to
scale that up and kind of give up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from during my
california springs and summers i spent
most of my days in the high sierras in
yosemite valley working
as a river guide and a rock climbing
instructor
i loved those
jobs but unfortunately they didn't pay
that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i had learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but it was fun
and i was good at it
and computer pro programming gave me the
same kind of satisfaction as solving
math problems and playing chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i loved
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again one of the things when i really
sit and think why why am i comfortable
taking risks what is it yeah um where i
come from i was really lucky when i was
growing up my dad used to actually
encourage my brother and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say sarah what
did you fail at this week and if i
didn't have something he would actually
be disappointed and i can vividly
remember coming home and saying dad dad
i tried out for this and i was horrible
and he would high-five me
and what i i didn't realize it was so
awesome i didn't realize it at the time
but it was he was teaching us that
failure is is not trying versus the
outcome
and so with spanx and everyone saying it
was such a bad idea initially and you
know i feel like i i feel much freer to
be willing to
you know fail in the traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the end
result and the more it's like working a
muscle the more you're willing to risk
something and maybe fail you realize
there's always a really awesome hidden
gift in it
it's either you meet someone new that
brings you to a different place in your
life or you learn something new or
and and so i always was really excited
by what how my life grew by every risk i
took i was lucky that i got started
early i mean always helps me get started
early and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down his office
on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in in a
sense and that that helped a lot and and
i was always fascinated by them i knew
what i wanted to do early and i think
that's a that's a huge advantage too
and then
you don't need you don't need a lot of
brains in this business i mean i've
always said if you've got an iq of 160
give away 30 points to somebody else
because you don't need it in investments
what you do need is emotional stability
you have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it right
but uh how uh how how did you uh what
was that extra thing where uh so many
will acknowledge that and yet we saw in
the current crisis they they panicked
why you went into seemingly potential
disasters like ge and goldman sachs
i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of competence the future has
no experts
right
we
entrepreneurs someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think
and
when you
when a entrepreneur get used to
failure
today say alibaba you succeed
well
our company won't last 102 years
why 102 years because every target every
goal we give to our team should be very
accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus one year one or two across three
centuries
so very accurate
we never see we are successful because
we are only 19 years old there is 83
years to go
so we will never see we are successful
we just survived 19 years we are lucky
but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes as entrepreneurs
don't learn from other people how they
succeed
learn from how these people fail
because
a lot of mba schools they teach you
success
successful case studies
when you read too many successful you
think you can be successful no
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some
business school came to alibaba write
case studies
they say this is alibaba and i said no
this is not alibaba they wanted me to
sign after one week
study they say this is case study
alibaba a no this is not me they say
jack you don't know you
[Applause]
and that's all right i signed
and
next to five years every year there is a
case study in qinghua university i was
invited sitting at the back listened to
the mba schools talk learning about our
case study and they always put a
competitor
competitor in alibaba who will succeed
for five years all they always agree
alibaba will die the competitor will win
but five years all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes
because the mistake most of the
companies i i talk to entrepreneurs most
of the mistakes they made are the same
most of the success reasons you don't
know the different reasons
so when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid mistakes
because when you see the mistakes when
you have this kind of problems you know
how to face
it an entrepreneur have a strong heart
towards the difficulties mistakes the
troubles the failures but should it be a
warm and soft heart to your colleagues
and to the customers we haven't had any
existential crisises knock on wood i
find i don't want to jinx anything
um
but we've had a lot of uh
kind of
dramatic events i remember
um there early on we only had 125
employees
when barnes and noble who the big united
states bookseller um opened their online
website to compete against us barnes
noble.com we'd had about a two-year
window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and 60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were um very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and
and so i called an all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so
scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms um
calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay
so and i said look you know it it's okay
to be afraid um but don't be afraid of
our competitors because they're never
gonna send us any money be afraid of our
customers and if we just stay focused on
them in in in in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to double down on the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them when i was a kid glenn i
was like
i knew i was gonna do something great
and had zero
reason to believe that right
like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not i think everybody has that
i would imagine that every kid
um
has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
going to be something great i remember
my twin brother uh he he would he'd be
in the mirror man he's like eight years
old we're eight years old he's singing
in here like he's a rock star right i
had to listen to that all the time
and and then i start thinking man man if
he's going to be a rock star
he's going to go on and be a big rock
star
and and and i can't you know
because i that that that wasn't my deal
i said what am i going to be
and then i thought i'm gonna be a
baseball player
i actually believed i was gonna be a
baseball player right dude i wasn't fast
enough i wasn't strong enough i didn't
have the arm i mean i had no talent
i didn't have the work ethic
you know i didn't have somebody pushing
me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man you're thinking
too small when i talk to people about
real estate don't do two units
got to start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32
right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too sure
if if you can just believe that you can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone as an entrepreneur you're every
department so
i was the before and after butt model
literally i took a picture of my own
butt took it to kinko's got it laminated
with and without spanx on stood in the
stores and i'm like hey look what this
can do for you um i was i was like the
packer and shipper i was the head of
sales i was everything and you learn
very quickly what you're good at and
what you're not good at and what you
enjoy and what you don't enjoy and
there's usually a correlation between
the two and so i often say as soon as
you can afford to hire your weaknesses
and a few years into spanx it was
abundantly clear that the lane that i
needed to stay in was inventing selling
promoting
spanx actually is never advertised spanx
is 18 years old and the first time we've
ever even sampled an ad was to uh in 16.
and so i was
sort of the the advertisement and and me
being out in the field talking about the
product and sharing the story of the why
why we're making this why it's better
was a big part of the formula and i
needed someone to be in the company
day-to-day running the daily operations
one part that i'm always um
very focused on is sort of the structure
of these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can
and making sure that people are you know
aligned properly not just that they say
i think this is sort of a very a very
legal kind of a framework to think about
what are people's incentives you know
are they going to be aligned or not and
i think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um you
know there's always a there's always a
uh there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you um
meet what's the prehistory of the
company before you got started um i find
that to be really instructive a set of
questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs um you know
that's like saying i married the first
person i met at the slot machines in las
vegas and you might hit the jackpot but
it's probably a really bad idea
and a much better answer is you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and uh and so i think this question of
um alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which was a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
[ __ ] wall yes and i was i always
every time i went around turned around
and went back home because i was too
scared i had crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city uh on long island in
the 80s when break dancing and rap and
all this stuff was happening yep and i
was really into break dancing i don't
know i don't look like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money probably if i went to
washington dc you know because the kids
in washington dc couldn't be as good as
the kids in new york we invented this
whole genre so i got my friend myron
who's my partner my sister just got her
driver's license and i convinced her to
drive us to washington dc and the whole
drive down i was having all that
self-doubt yeah you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and i stink yeah and so i
was almost talking myself out i was
building the wall of doubt up brick by
brick in my own head yeah and when we
got there we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and a crowd
gathered around and ultimately after i
did my thing more people came i took my
hat i passed it around we made about 200
i paid my sister for the gas money and
then myron and i split 82. 41 each and
this guy you know he's counting up the
money and he's counting up the money and
he gets all the money and then he
sprints over to me and he gives me a
bear hug and he goes jess we're
rich
[Laughter]
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall and i realized i
could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that two
weeks ago i went i went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based i dropped the
meat dude that's so i want to do that i
did that for a week last week yeah and i
felt amazing i had a lot more gas just
from all the plants i think but cleaning
it out
that's really too much information for
me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation and less pain
yeah i hadn't noticed i have a little
bit of inflammation in in my hands but
yeah that hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changing changer yeah
and uh when he said
dude you're eating the metal man
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middle man
you're eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you can go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what am i doing
eating the middle man
i ain't a middle man guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like i need that was the line in
the show that did me and i had been
thinking about it too i've eaten meat
for 60 years i grew up on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is freaking
this all day long oh wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crashed at 3 30. hard crash i
mean like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what you doing at 3 30. i got him i got
a meeting yeah that meeting was on that
nap dude and when i hit it i'm talking
coma
[Laughter]
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i can't take a nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
that's how good my energy do you think
you're gonna stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes do you
think i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm
not a fanatic guys so yeah so it's a
little meat here and there or something
i'm just gonna eat what makes me feel
best yeah so
i don't care if it was meat if it was
pork it was bacon but right now
um
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't i haven't missed the meat
wow
my digestion's better
you know
my energy is freaking great
so
i don't know man
[Music]
if you want another amazing video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we don't love this product but we
think others will love it you know
that's not really how it works if you
don't love it don't expect others will
either your relationship with time is
such a key component
of your life